[Música]
assim que eu soube que o nosso técnico
recife acontecer aqui nesse lugar
minha primeira reação foi então chácara
eu acho que esse espaço aqui dizia ser
um espaço completamente diferente eu
queria
acho que é exatamente aqui onde eu tô
vivendo uma grande árvore esse dever ser
um parque de um outro perfil
eu peguei a minha bicicleta na minha
casa e vem trabalhando até aqui nos 8km
e eu fui observando que assim como esse
parque existem vários outros locais na
cidade que eu gostaria que fosse
diferente não só eu como muitos de vocês
aqui
e esses lugares não são diferentes
porque nós não participamos do processo
de decisão desses lugares no processo de
decisão se dá no âmbito político
a maioria das pessoas não faz isso que
não gosta de política
eu gosto política desde que eu me
entendo por gente
desde muito novinho não gostava de
assistir os horários gratuitos sabe os
dingos dos políticos se vocês me
perguntarem até hoje o que significa a
sigla de cada partido político no brasil
eu vou saber inclusive aqueles que nem
existem mais
estava conversando com um amigo meu me
senti é dizer que gostava muito política
e da política desde os 12 anos de idade
12 chamava pra brincar a gente tinha
sete anos
você dizia que e assistir o horário
político desses caras aí os candidatos à
prefeitura do recife no ano de 1992
deixava de brincar com meu amigo pra
ficar assistindo aqui no caminho da
nossa escola e comemorava quando passava
porque a gente gostava e vaiava o que a
gente gosta da coisa de criança
curioso ver que são esses mesmos
sujeitos então e até hoje né
mas eu nunca consegui decifrar a gente
exatamente o código da política nunca
foi filiado a partido político nunca
participei assim ativamente da campanha
e nunca consegui decifrar o código
a política talvez porque a política não
esteja aí para ser decifrado das pessoas
porque as pessoas que lá estão não têm
interesse que novas pessoas entre o
talvez porque como muitos de nós
eu estive muito tempo preocupado comigo
meio dos dez anos fiz duas graduações
duas graduações tem aí uma carreira
promissora na iniciativa privada
foi aí que de dois anos pra cá eu
comecei a tomar contato com um dos
serviços públicos que sofre sofre
influência direta da política de
educação
comecei a colaborar de forma voluntária
pela gestão da educação municipal
aqui em nossa cidade o primeiro
movimento formação em administração
gestão vamos olhar os indicadores
primeiro contato aqui nível de
proficiência dos alunos da rede
municipal de educação do recife no 9º
ano do ensino fundamental à nossa antiga
8ª série o nível de proficiência em
matemática acentuou de alunos que têm um
nível de proficiência considerado
avançado 0% considerados proficiente 2%
aí tem um percentual de básico 36% e
insuficiente 62% a nossa rede municipal
de educação entrega a criança no ano com
62 consideradas insuficientes em
matemática a tudo bem matemática mata
mata é mais difícil realidade português
é tão catastrófica quando quando nós
olharmos a posição do recife no índice
de desenvolvimento da educação básica
nós vamos ver que das 27 capitais nós
estamos lá no fim da lista e 23º
isso é o que nos dizem os indicadores
a gente toma contato com a realidade
mais de perto quem vai ver as escolas os
estudantes a gente vê que a coisa é
muito pior
eu tive a infelicidade de visitar
escolas sem janelas escolas sem porta de
escolas onde a cisterna um escola
principalmente da cisterna foi
construída ao lado da força ea cisterna
que abastece o bebedouro das crianças
houve escolas que não têm a mínima
condição de oferecer aos nossos
estudantes um processo sábio e efetivo
de ensino aprendizagem
as imagens falam por si só mas o que
chama mais atenção é ver o quanto isso
gera vulnerabilidade social das crianças
que mais precisam da escola quando a
escola deixa de ser o epicentro da
comunidade
ela abre espaço para tudo que era
invadir a vida dessas crianças que não
têm de fato um background que não tem um
alicerce da família ea escola
então nesse processo nós chegamos um dia
na escola pra conversar com a diretora e
ela disse que não podia receber que
estava com dois alunos é na sala delas
na sala dela é que foram pegas na escola
brincando de traficar drogas
eles substituirão sal e açúcar ou
cocaína e crack
ou então a criança que não conseguia
mais freqüentar a escola porque no dia
em que ela não teve aula e teve que
voltar mais cedo sozinha no caminho de
volta para casa
ela foi estuprada essa criança um menino
de 8 anos eu comecei a me perguntar o
que tem que ser assim
será que uma cidade como a nossa recife
não tem condição de oferecer uma
educação pública de qualidade das nossas
crianças
obviamente que tudo isso que eu falei
aqui pra vocês não é mérito ou demérito
de única gestão é um processo histórico
e aí de novo a minha formação de
administradores levou a ver os números
na verdade números assim que a gente tem
feito reconhecimento instante orçamento
municipal da prefeitura do recife para o
ano de 2015 aprovada a menos de 60 dias
atrás na câmara municipal de vereadores
810 milhões
em reais a gerir uma rede que atende
aproximadamente 88 mil alunos
a gente vive um pelo outro a gente vai
encontrar aqui uma despesa média mensal
e setecentos e sessenta e dois reais por
ano
eu garanto que qualquer um aqui consegue
matricular seu filho uma boa escola
particular
com esse valor ora se há dinheiro porque
não há a prestação do serviço
dentre as tantas reflexões que eu fiz
com as outras pessoas está a de que para
o brasileiro não só para a resistência a
um entendimento errôneo que o que é
público é ruim eo que é privado é bom
ora se eu estou a todo momento querendo
tirar o meu filho da escola pública e
colocá lo na privada porque o que é
público é ruim o que o que é privado é
bom eu não vou cobrar que haja uma
melhoria efetiva do ensino público eu
vou orientar o meu pensamento enquanto
pai enquanto o livro de família pra que
o meu filho saia do público e vá para o
privado
isso aconteceu na saúde na educação na
mobilidade em vários dos aspectos que
influenciam a vida de todos nós
vocês estão concordando comigo pensa em
quantos serviços públicos vocês consomem
desses três ambientes que eu falei
a maioria de nós foi privado né então as
pessoas não querem mais saber
elas deixam de cobrar quem é
efetivamente tem que fazer as coisas que
são os políticos tanto porque o que é
privado é bom eo que é público é ruim
quanto porque há uma rejeição crescente
em relação à política
a constatação fatal é que as pessoas não
estão nem aí os políticos e os políticos
não estão nem aí para as crianças
vamos assistir aqui
qual foi o último livro que vocês aqui
leram sobre política
quem aqui acompanha diariamente o
semanalmente o noticiário político da
nossa cidade do nosso estado do país
vamos fazer uma coisa um pouquinho mais
desafiadora e aí eu vou precisar de toda
a sinceridade de vocês nesse momento me
respondam com muita rapidez mas muita
rapidez mesmo levantando a mão quem se
lembra em quem votou para deputado
estadual nas últimas eleições
quem não lembrou as últimas eleições
aconteceram há 70 dias atrás
talvez isso aconteça porque as políticas
no brasil tem se tornado sinônimo de
corrupção
as pessoas que estão lá hoje estiveram
lá durante tanto tempo e fato nos
inspiram ou porque eles não estavam
fazendo aquilo que deveriam fazer ou
porque estavam fazendo uma coisa que é
absolutamente elas deveriam estar
fazendo mas o mais difícil é a gente
olhar a perspectiva futura e ver que os
novos líderes políticos que surgem no
brasil não só não nos inspiram como nos
carros um verdadeiro desespero até uma
reação organizada e junho de 2013
mostrou isso de uma forma muito claro
para o brasil
há uma grande insatisfação e muitos
falam até em crise de representatividade
de lá pra cá o parlamento tem observado
uma grande explosão de engajamento mas
há sempre um engajamento no movimento da
sociedade civil organizada no coletivo
na mobilização a associação e nunca na
política partidária
ora num qualquer democracia madura ela
tem a organização da sociedade civil em
peso muito semelhante à nossa democracia
representativa mas essa não é a
realidade do país ainda ainda é a
política institucional à política
partidária que tem o maior poder de
transformar nossa realidade e aí a gente
volta para os números do orçamento anual
da união 2 trilhões e 500 bilhões
em reais o que a dificuldade de escrever
10 sair orçamento anual de uma
prefeitura como do recife que é de 6
bilhões de reais é maior que talvez o
maior empresário desse país
talvez não juntar nos orçamentos de
todas as energias do brasil
nós não vamos chegar novamente à
prefeitura do município tem capacidade
de fazer as coisas pelo menos com
dinheiro a mas as pessoas que estão lá
talvez não seja competente e pior as
pessoas que elegem essas pessoas parecem
não estar interessado ea gente começa a
fenômenos como esse é um fenômeno
caricato se reproduzindo nos dias de
hoje somos nós os cidadãos que ela
gêmeas as 75 mil pessoas que são eleitas
a cada quatro anos no brasil somos nós
que determinamos quem vai estar lá nos
apresentando
eu costumo dizer que democracia é uma
cadeira que não podem ficar vazia no
momento que nós cidadãos de bem
decidimos nos retirar e aí só uma oração
não é que todo mundo esteja lá e mal mas
no momento que nós decidimos nos
retiradas dessa cadeira alguém foi lá e
sentou e vai continuar sentando
independente de nós termos interesse
pela política ou não temos interesse
pela política
eu comecei a fazer essa reflexão para
mim mesmo
gostei de política eu tô aqui indignado
com essa situação que eu tive a
oportunidade de me aproximar a
infelicidade de me aproximar porque é o
mesmo
não me aproxima da política porque eu
não cobro o vereador em que eu voltei há
dois anos atrás porque não acompanha a
execução do orçamento municipal
na minha cidade porque o mesmo não
participo da política e nas minhas
buscas
felizmente encontrei uma rede de pessoas
que pensa exatamente como eu talvez não
exatamente mas muito próximo às pessoas
formar em são paulo há dois anos atrás
uma rede de ação política
a organização multipartidária que está
em todos os níveis da política
influenciam a transformação dessa
realidade
nós estamos baseados em três pilares
coisa que é difícil a gente vê hoje na
política regional ética transparência e
sustentabilidade
estamos construindo os conceitos da
nossa rede coletivamente de uma forma
como deve ser
hoje somos 271 pessoas espalhadas pelo
brasil inteiro
pessoas como pedro henrique que saiu da
maior da universidade mais conceituadas
do mundo pra ir pra comunidade do
vidigal aplicá-la o que ele aprendeu
sobre arquitetura pessoas com daniel que
se emocionou no primeiro encontro da
nossa rede
ao falar do quanto o lixo se espalha com
belém do pará toca ele e ricardo que
decidiu numa cidade como são paulo
enfrentar o desafio de fazer um mandato
transparente ético e sustentável
ele hoje exerce um mandato piloto da
nossa rede participa do nosso concelho e
nós participamos participando do
conselho do mandato dele
estamos representados hoje em tom quase
todos os partidos políticos relevantes
do país e das pessoas que estão filiadas
a partidos políticos a pessoas da
extrema direita e da extrema esquerda
todos disponíveis para abrir mão das
suas ideologias partidárias
em troca desse tripé e para de fato
renovar a política
o nosso objetivo é até 2020 com por 10%
do congresso nacional onde já tem bem
pragmático que só assim a gente acredita
que vai começar a efetivamente fazer uma
transformação
os caminhos de participação política
gente
são muitos e esse não é o único deles
que vocês já difícil fazer a gestão
entre vida pessoal e vida profissional
o bota vida política no meio sempre fica
um pouco mais complicado
inclusive estamos com processo de
seleção aberto na nossa rede
quem quiser participar basta procurar no
google fez vamos encontrar
nós estamos enfrentando o desafio de
entrar no sistema que parece ser feito
para não mudar as pessoas que estão lá
hoje não têm o mínimo interesse que nós
estejamos e talvez não consigamos
mas nós vamos continuar tentando
discutindo se informando encontrando-se
pra fazer a revolução que nós queremos
fazer
nós entendemos que para alguns cidadãos
brasileiros muito mais do que um direito
de participar da política nós temos o
dever pois diferente daquelas crianças
que a gente vem aqui no comecinho
nós tivemos acesso à informação que nos
tornam diferente diferente não que
aumenta a nossa responsabilidade
eu tenho a felicidade de gostar de
política desde criança não precisa
gostar é possível fazer uma revolução na
política transformando nós mesmos ea
história da humanidade se nós olharmos
está cheia de exemplos de pessoas
fizeram exatamente isso começaram
individualmente uma atividade política e
mudaram a realidade desses locais para o
mal ou para o bem e aí vou tomar
emprestado aqui uma frase que atribuiu
seu grande dizer que nós já vemos ea
revolução que esperamos do mundo
na verdade o finalzinho de pensamento
dele é o mais interessante nós não
devemos esperar pelos outros
nós não devemos até porque nós não vamos
conseguir esperar que a política
institucional partidária se transforma
com os políticos
eles se transformando nós temos que
fazer parte da política e transformá lá
é muito difícil fazer isso acontecer mas
com articulação com vontade e
principalmente com que a atitude é
possível a gente fazer isso acontecer
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]